j'étais petit je m'appelle eric montée
dori et j'apparais dans la vidéo ils
auront 50 ans en 2021
c'est mon neveu qui m'a envoyé un
message sur ma sur mon téléphone en me
disant ton truc de dingue regarde la
vidéo qui est envoyée c'était une
émission qui passaient tous les
vendredis sur fr3 qui s'appelait
vendredi grand public ils sont mis dans
mon collège et ils ont interviewé à peu
près entre 400 et 500 élèves et ils en
ont sélectionné cinq mais j'étais parmi
des 5
si vous deviez donner un adjectif au
collège ce serait lequel
je serai pas mais je dis ce serait mon
prison pour moi c'est une prison porto a
commandé place c'est un homme qui on
commande la france entière car voir
l'école st principal tu envoies dans la
russie afrique
partons dans ses commandes et ça ne va
pas évoluer trente ans après j'ai
toujours un problème avec l'autorité
j'ai du mal avec sa société et marcher
sur l'ailé gauche
j'ai connu bien des patins par ton avis
dans les 12 partout on attend la fin
j'ai vu occuper ma ville par des combis
forme qui était pas vraiment viré et qui
se prenait pour des dérapages préférence
chanteur j'ai crié sur tous les toits
ce que je pensais de toi société
comme un chanteur préféré
j'ai beaucoup pris exemple sur lui
d'ailleurs c'est pas elle qui m'a éduqué
d'accord mais il m'a donné une certaine
idée de la société qui est vrai
d'ailleurs non renault n'est plus mon
idole mais c'est quelqu'un que j'aime
encore ses chansons ses textes dans les
soirées avec mes amis tard le soir ça
finit souvent par des chansons grenon ce
qui est très bizarre c'est que j'étais
un fan de renaud
mais j'avais rien du tout comparé avec
lui en looks tous mes papiers mérono il
avait vraiment leur look cheveux longs
mois j'étais pas du tout comme ça que
j'aime a une fille c'est son caractère
ses tendresses voit bien sûr qu'elle
soit bien aussi quand j'étais petit je
rêvais toujours des bonbons et bleue et
costume ainsi tous des bruits apport de
3 jeux combien sélection pour moi les
cheveux blancs ou quarante ans après ça
n'a pas changé toujours des brunes
j'étais quand même sans fil prend pas ce
que je pense
j'avais quand même que mes parents
allaient voir ce à quoi l'on pince
chronos un point puisque déjà énorme
kespa commune à billets
sa tête une vue sur son spa un mille de
sa génération
patinant aussi j'ai de grands enfants
j'avais un garçon de 30 ans roma et ma
fille océane de 20 ans non je compatis
avec earl générationnel avec mes enfants
et puis mon su me garder je suis très à
l'écouté de ce qui regarde ce qu'ils
écoutent donc du coup ça me reste je
suis allé en coupe
et puis j'aurais transmis aussi des
choses des choses qui nous lisent adhère
donc c'est plutôt cool aussi dans la rue
ça représente quoi pour vous beaucoup
parce que ça on apprend qu on est des
copains découvrir les personnes
vachement différentes les unes aux
autres personnes qui boivent besoin
désespéré ou bien consulter dans ce one
can contraire au rheu bien dans leur
peau
quelque part je me dis ça m'a rassuré
parce que finalement j'ai encore des
valeurs que j'avais à 13 ans que j'ai
toujours bon après avec avec un peu plus
d'expérience de la vie mais je me dis
j'ai pas trop changé du haut de mes 50
ans de la façon de nier je m'exprimais
il ya des choses qui m'ont fait rire je
suis je pense des pires son petit drogba
c'est leur problème d'abord et moi je
n'ai sûrement qui doit avoir une raison
c'est pas tout c'est dire qu'un dé
convaincre genka c'est un pauvre con
chicken patienter tout ça c'est sûr qui
sait ce qu'un ta santé mais avant de
dire savoir pourquoi et c'est ça mes
amis qui l'ont vu que mon âge et mon dit
pareil qu'à la bienveillance que tu
avais on a vraiment de la chance d'avoir
comme ami donc du coup à fond me fait
plaisir
j'essaierai de françois des maisons pour
les pros qui vit heureux comme tout le
monde voit comme tout le monde j'ai
énormément de courriers notamment une
qui m'a marqué c'est un prêtre qui
m'avait écrit au moins trois pages sur
la sensibilité sur le qu'il avait
retrouvé et la bienveillance que j'avais
un par rapport par rapport aux autres
qu'est ce que c'est raté sa vie pour
vous pour moi c'est une personne qui est
dans son fauteuil avec t pain ses
pantoufles bien chaudes son journal
afrique chez choix j'avais comme ça je
ne peux pas je n'ai pas la prétention de
dire que c'est raté sa vie ou pas parce
que chacun mène sa vie et réussir sa vie
je pense déjà cédé ans en phase avec soi
même et essayer d'être rendre les gens
qui nous entourent de les aimer le mieux
possible et c'était mieux avant parce
qu'il y avait
gst sensations ou la communication ou la
fraternité où l'amitié où la synergie
étaient vraiment présente et le mot ami
était était vraiment était vraiment
sincère
paris - africain un endroit que je suis
sorti aujourd'hui dirait un petit eric
boisse un peu à l'école quand même tu
verras recettes servir le petit eric
qu'il me dirait certainement fait moi
pas chier et surtout n'oubliez pas vous
abonner à une société